>> THANK YOU.
>> Jason: BEST REPORTERS SO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT AND THANK YOU FOR
GREAT PIECE YOU PUT OUT.
ALSO, YESTERDAY, HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE CHAIRMAN, THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES
AND THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY
ACTUALLY WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO VIEW
DOCUMENTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN ASKING AND WERE
UNDER SUBPOENA FOR MONTHS.
BUT SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT
NUNES AND GOWDY WERE ONLY
BRIEFED.
ANOTHER MEETING IS SCHEDULED
FOR THEM TO SEE IT.
BUT THE BEST WAY TO GET THE
INFORMATION IS TALK TO SOMEONE
IN THE MEETING.
TREY GOWDY AND ALSO JOHN
RATCLIFFE FROM TEXAS.
BOTH ARE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
AND BEEN THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON
THIS BEAUTIFUL FRIDAY NIGHT.
CHAIRMAN GOWDY, DID YOU GET A
LOT OF LIP SERVICE?
DID YOU GET TO READ THE
DOCUMENTS?
WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU?
>> JASON, IT WAS A PRODUCTIVE
MEETING YESTERDAY.
I THINK EVERY QUESTION I ASKED
THE BUREAU AND THE DEPARTMENT
NOW UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
RELEVANT, MATERIAL, THEY ARE
SPECIFIC AND POINTED.
THERE IS A REASON CONGRESS
WANTS TO KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTIONS.
IT WAS A CONSTRUCTIVE -- I
KNOW THAT IS NOT GOOD NEWS
FROM THE MEDIA STANDPOINT THAT
WE HAD A BORING, CONSTRUCTIVE
MEETING YESTERDAY BUT THAT IS
WHAT IT WAS.
SO CONSTRUCTIVE WE HAVE AGREED
TO MEET NEXT WEEK.
YOU ASK IF WE SAW SOMETHING.
I CAN LEARN WITH MY EARS AND
MY EYES.
I CAN GOT TO ASK QUESTIONS.
WE WERE PROSECUTORS AND I KNOW
THE QUESTIONS TO ASK IN AN
INVESTIGATION LIKE THIS.
YESTERDAY WAS ACTUALLY
PRODUCTIVE.
>> Jason: WHEN DO YOU
ACTUALLY GET TO SEE THEM?
>> WELL, LET ME SAY THIS.
I WORKED IN ALL THREE BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS TENSION, THERE
INTENTIONAL TENSION PUT
BETWEEN THE BRANCHES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
THAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAN'T
SEE.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH THAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAN'T SEE.
THERE ARE THINGS WE DO, JASON,
AS YOU RECALL IN CONGRESS WE
DON'T LET ANYBODY ELSE SEE.
THAT TENSION WE HAVE GOT TO
WORK THROUGH.
I LEARNED INFORMATION THIS
WEEK.
YOU STILL WANT TO SEE THE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY HAVE TAKEN THE REQUEST
UNDER ADVISEMENT AND
REGRETTING FARTHER TAKING THIS
APPROACH, MEETING EYEBALL TO
EYEBALL OPPOSED TO EXCHANGING
LETTERS AND SEEING WHO CAN
LEAK THEM THE QUICKEST.
THAT IS NOT CONSTRUCTIVE.
WHAT IS CONSTRUCTIVE IS TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION AND WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD ACCESS
THE DOCUMENT.
>> Jason: IT'S A SHAME THAT
NUNES HAD TO ISSUE A SUBPOENA
AND THREATEN CONTEMPT AND THE
SOUTHERN GENTLEMAN IN TREY
GOWDY COMING OUT.
I'M GLAD YOU ARE MAKING
INCREMENTAL PROGRESS STEP BY
STEP.
I WANT TO GO TO JOHN RATCLIFFE
AND GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
JAMES COMEY.
HE IS FRESH OFF A BOOK TOUR
AND HE HAS SAID A LOT OF
THINGS AND WE HAVE LEARNED
MORE ABOUT DIRECTOR COMEY.
HAS HE MADE THE SITUATION
BETTER OR WORSE FOR HIMSELF
AFTER THE BOOK TOUR AND THE
THINGS WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
HIS ACTIONS WHILE HE WAS THE
F.B.I. DIRECTOR?
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
ONE THING THAT HAS COME OUT OF
JAMES COMEY'S INTERVIEWS ON
THE BOOK TOUR AND THE RELEASE
OF HIS SECRET MEMOS, IT'S
IRONIC TO ME THAT HE IS THE
ONE THAT CREATED THE
ALLEGATION OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
NOW HE IS THE SAME PERSON WHO
HAS EFFECTIVEL TORPEDOED THE
ABILITY TO PROVE OBSTRUCTION.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE THE 15
PAGES OF THE SECRET MEMOS
NEVER MENTION "OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE" A SINGLE TIME.
IN FACT, ONE OF THE MEMOS DOES
THE OPPOSITE.
IT SAYS THAT IT IS AN
ADMISSION BY THE FORMER
DIRECTOR THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ASKED HIM TO FULLY INVESTIGATE
WHETHER OR NOT ANYONE, THAT
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THAT IS WHY TREY AND I REFER
TO THE MEMO AS DEFENSE EXHIBIT
"A" IN ANY CHARGES THAT WOULD
BE BROUGHT AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
I THINK HE HAS ALSO HURT THE
MUELLER CASE AND THE ABILITY
TO PROVE THAT.
YOU CAN'T BUILD A CASE AROUND
A STAR WITNESS WHO HAS DAMAGED
HIS OWN CREDIBILITY AND HURT
HIS OWN REPUTATION AS I THINK
JAMES COMEY HAS DONE OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS ON THIS BOOK
TOUR.
>> Jason: DO YOU THINK --
DOES HE HAVE ANY LEGAL
JEOPARDY HIMSELF, DIRECTOR
COMEY?
>> I THINK THE BEST ANSWER TO
THAT, JASON, WILL COME WITH
THE RELEASE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT.
YOU KNOW WE ALL ANTICIPATE
THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN SHORTLY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ HAS PROVEN HIMSELF TO
BE A FAIR UMPIRE.
SOMEONE WHO CALLS BALLS AND
STRIKES FAIRLY AND WHERE
APPROPRIATE MAKING CRIMINAL
REFERRAL OF THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
HAVING NOT HAVING SEEN THE
REPORT I'D BE SURPRISED IF
THEY DON'T FIND MISCONDUCT BY
FORMER DIRECTOR COMEY.
I THINK HE WILL FIND THAT HE
VIOLATED THE EMPLOYMENT
AGREEMENT AND MADE
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURES OF
THE F.B.I. DOCUMENTS.
WHETHER THEY ARE CLASSIFIED OR
NOT, THEY ARE IMPROPER LEAKS.
I THINK YOU WILL FIND HE MADE
DEMONSTRABLY FALSE STATEMENTS.
THEY HAVE CONFLICTED WITH THE
PUBLIC INTERVIEWS HE IS GIVEN.
I THINK MICHAEL HOROWITZ WILL
MAKE IF RECOMMENDATION.
>> Jason: WHEN DO YOU THINK
WE WILL SEE THIS?
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT OUT OF
THIS?
DO YOU THINK THERE WILL BE ANY
CRIMINAL REFERRALS COMING FROM
THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS I TRY TO
AVOID ACCUSING PEOPLE OF
COMMITTING CRIMES.
THAT WAS MY OLD JOB.
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH TO DO IT.
ALL THREE OF US HAVE
TREMENDOUS CONFIDENCE IN
MICHAEL HOROWITZ, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
A FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
A STRAIGHT ARROW.
FACT-CENTRIC.
I THINK THE REASON IT IS
TAKING LONGER, JASON, THAN HE
ANTICIPATED IS HE IS FINDING
MORE INFORMATION.
SO WHAT I WOULD TELL MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE HOUSE GIVE
HIM THE TIME, INDEPENDENCE AND
THE RESOURCES TO DO EVERYTHING
HE NEEDS TO DO.
I KNOW WE WANTED IT IN
FEBRUARY AND MARCH AND THAT IS
HUMAN NATURE TO WANT IT
QUICKER BUT I WANT IT TO BE
COMPLETE.
I WANT IT TO BE FULSOME.
I WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN WHAT
HOROWITZ HAS DONE.
IF HE COULD REPRESENT THAT HE
IS ACCESSED EVERY DOCUMENT AND
EVERY WITNESS, I MEAN HE FOUND
THE PAGE-STROZK TEXT AND FOUND
SOME WERE DELETED AND THROUGH
HIS HELP THEY WERE
RECONSTRUCTED.
I'M AS IMPATIENT AS EVERYONE
ELSE.
I KNOW THIS.
I WANT HOROWITZ TO PRESENT A
FULSOME PICTURE WHEN HE COMES.
IF IT MEANS WAITING ANOTHER
COUPLE OF WEEKS SO BE IT.
>> Jason: DO YOU HAVE A
DATE?
DO WE HAVE A DATE WHEN YOU ARE
HAVING THE HEARING?
>> WE HAVE SET ONE AND WE
MOVED IT.
YOU REMEMBER HOW THAT USED TO
BE.
WE ARE SHOOTING FOR THE FIRST
WEEK OF JUNE.
I WILL SAY WITH THIS CAVEAT.
YOU KNOW HOROWITZ, JASON.
HE IS NOT GIVING ME ANY
UPDATES ON HIS INVESTIGATION,
NOR SHOULD HE, NOR WOULD I
ASK.
LIKE TO SCHEDULE THE HEARING
AND I WILL PICK A DATE AND HE
WILL TELL ME WHETHER OR NOT HE
THINKS HE WILL MAKE THE TARGET
DATE OR NOT.
I HAVE NO INSIDE INFORMATION
AND I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO.
>> Jason: REAL QUICKLY,
CONGRESSMAN RATCLIFFE IN TEN
SECONDS, DIRECTOR MUELLER.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT
CONTINUES TO GO ON?
WILL IT IMPACT THE 2018
ELECTION OR WILL HE WRAP THIS
THING UP?
>> HI HAS TO BE CAREFUL -- I
THINK HE HAS TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
MUELLER HAS TO NOT MAKE THE
MISTAKE THAT THEY CRITICIZED
COMEY FOR TO ALLOW THE
INVESTIGATION TO IMPACT AN
ELECTION.
WHICH THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS AGREED HAPPENED IN
2016.
>> Jason: GENTLEMEN, IT'S